but also does anybody really think that
if joe biden is elected president
he's going to be the one calling the
shots
talk about separation of powers joe
biden again yesterday because it was a
day that ended in y
on the few days that his handlers allow
him
to broadcast outside of his basement
he had another big error joe biden was
giving
his typically soaring rhetoric in an
interview with a local nbc affiliate
take a listen to his oratory
what's the president doing look
venezuela's top line message is
president trump's policy is an abject
failure
that's the top line message for those of
you who are not familiar with
teleprompters
or with with political notes sometimes
you'll see the top line message that's
the point you've got to drive home
but that's not you don't say the top
line message that's the part that you
keep quiet
and keep in your head unless you don't
know what to say you've forgotten how to
conduct
politics you're not really in control of
your rational faculties
and you're just reading off of a
teleprompter which is obviously what joe
biden is doing
he's not able even to form these
sentences and it's funny because now
you know the left always projects so
whatever is true of them they just
throw on to the other political party
yesterday they were trying to suggest
that trump had
a cognitive decline or he'd had a stroke
or something crazy like that
regardless of what you think about trump
you might hate him you might
hate his policies you might be a
conservative and hate him because there
are disagreements among conservatives
one thing we're talking about today
you can't say the guy is senile
the guy will get up and give a
three-hour speech without a teleprompter
and he'll keep the audience engaged for
the whole thing
in fact he keeps the audience more
engaged with that a teleprompter than he
does with a teleprompter but certainly
he can read a teleprompter
the same cannot be said of joe biden
whether you like joe biden or you hate
joe biden
the guy is obviously in decline and so
if you elect him
what are you electing you're electing
the democratic party apparatus
which far from a separation of powers is
this liberal establishment connected to
the media connected to the universities
connected to
hollywood connected to big technology
today connected obviously to the party
itself
and they are pushing a radical message
that involves violence in the streets
that involves tearing down
our institutions and our statues
and the great men that those statues
represent there is nothing
conservative about that at all i hope
you enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]